California
one of the company's most culturally
rich and diverse cities not to mention a
hotbed for some of the world's most
extraordinary Foods I'm close to the
site of LA's new amazing football
stadium the future home to the Rams and
the Chargers while the area awaits the
business a new stadium will bring
there's one restaurant whose doors are
in danger of closing family owned and
operated since 2002 Madea's Bakery and
Bistro has earned a great reputation for
its Freshly Baked Goods unfortunately an
intervention is needed because frankly
Madeira this place is in trouble silence
it for 30 seconds please stop eating
Madam Carrie I've been here for the last
90 minutes I understand while the
wrestling is struggling Medias is
officially closed can you all follow me
please I ain't gonna do too well with
him oh my Lord
are you nervous of course
this is Hell on Wheels it's a
state-of-the-art kitchen and more
importantly this is my epicenter staffed
with the most extraordinary team
everything we do we put passion into it
I'm about to show you something that
we've been secretly filming over the
last couple of weeks and trust me it
speaks to why this restaurant is failing
watch carefully please
foreign
can you go down to King's market and see
if they have any steaks oh we don't have
french toast right now 86 spinach 86
french fries catfish salmon croquette
stop what you're doing and go get me
some eggs because this is not gonna last
us
that ain't no customer service
this is the wrong plate but I'm gonna go
ahead and send it out Terry has a lazy
ass daughter named Tiffany she doesn't
like to work hard she can stand there
behind the counter and chit chat with
all the guys that come in
I don't know why you guys are just
stacking them up here
double bag this stuff Devin what exactly
are you doing the employees they just
fear her there's no respect
kiss my ass
imbeciles [__] imbeciles oh no
why does it come to this
12 hours a day seven days a week for the
last 16 years
where are the standards
staff anybody what's happened no one
listens no one listens no one gives a
flying [__]
watching you carry the owner this
morning
mixing dredging cooking cleaning washing
sweeping up you did not strike me as the
owner there this morning
they know that help is coming but what
they don't know is that help is me I
needed to know the issues before I even
stepped foot inside so my team told the
restaurant that they are trying out for
a renovation series while they've been
interviewed we installed hidden cameras
throughout the restaurant and have been
secretly recording surveillance footage
since we left
who Gordon Ramsay what yeah Alice Alex
nice to see you all wow let's just get
one thing clear I've just been sat out
there for the last hour eating some of
the worst Food I've ever tasted in my
entire career
really wow
how's business been generally bad bad
yeah why do you think business is bad
not a lot of customers every other
business this afternoon and has been for
the last three hours have been packed
why do people come here
um should I tell you because they can't
get in anywhere else oh okay yeah this
is not Patrick malloy's this is the last
resort
I'm pretty pissed I thought it was good
most feedback are pretty positive
[Music]
you know
I've got some bad news for all four of
you excuse me two seconds
ladies and gentlemen
stop eating
Forks down
everybody the restaurant is closed
all of you follow me outside
right now
let's go
let me introduce you to Health on Wheels
the heart of my command center and more
importantly every individual behind
there are serious experts over the last
few weeks your restaurant has been under
surveillance I want you all to have a
look
I am horrified it's [__] embarrassing
it's in New York I know
these tables are so sticky it's
disgusting
kissing in the middle of service
oh my God I want to be out of here seven
[__] years ago and I can't get out of
here that's [__] honestly
we need to understand it was that I run
this [__] place you gotta do that and
you don't do that
across
I cannot believe we just ate there
shocking I mean it's just disappointing
because you expect people to be up to
code it's gonna take a big turnaround
for me to come back here
cross-contamination
raw chicken with cooked food
that's an acceptable excuse me that's
ineffectible you're right we're doing
wrong
you go to the gym and you walk in your
restaurant half [__] naked you know
it's something that you're used to doing
and it's just bad habits if you're
running a business
it's not a catwalk
Irma you might have to man The Post oh
really and you go wash the dishes no I'm
gonna go watch the ram game
time to go sightseeing morning guys
we're good
smile please everybody my names if you
play
hey
I'm posing as a French tourist so I can
go deep undercover I lived in Paris for
three years on do two years
I learned to speak French whilst
training as a chef in Paris in my early
days so this was the perfect opportunity
new girl and me
I have a pretty good idea where we'll go
for lunch all right well look it looks
like one of my favorite restaurants La
serengeta let's see if they'll let us
join in the fun guys all right thank you
hopefully I won't be spotted
all right we got customers
welcome to last Saturday guys great
great thank you we got it to langta
coming in Missy
this place looks great
that's it we're all doing dishes that
any Mexican restaurant worth their
margaritas and salt should be able to
make
sure
yeah we'll have that as well okay very
good one more thing yeah you want to do
breakfast burrito thank you having seen
the practices in that kitchen for my
surveillance team
look at this I'm not expecting much
last time this thing saw a liquor paint
really really good
all right
the sweat came off his [__] nose into
my suit what I look look at this
spilling over like a volcano
that tastes disgusting
a burrito okay
okay be careful the place a little bit
hard okay you have to make everybody
happy every single baby people has to be
happy with the food I don't think the
food's a problem here
that is gross I'm not going to tell you
what that reminds me of
like the inside of my great granddad's
Underpants
okay Mahi with the garlic I think you're
the Mahi ladies it's here yeah no it's
here you don't like spicy right that's
beyond the no spicy lady okay I'm the
one who who ordered my Hima just put the
plate down okay there you go so this is
a salmon no that's mahi mahi that's the
same thing
no composure it's just running around
like a headless chicken right I've seen
enough thank you I'll be back okay okay
see you later
please follow me Junior oh my God
young man can you ask Marco and
everybody come and join me right now
please young man can we stand here
please
hello Laura hi please stand next to
Junior thank you I've had better days
what I've just experienced
or shocking I just want to say you can
never ever
step inside this dining room again
dripping of sweat from your nose in to
customers food
how disgusting is this place
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
have your attention please would you all
put your knife and forks down young lady
can you get me everybody out of that
kitchen now please thank you we are not
eating any more [__] for today
[Music]
I've seen enough
that
was
embarrassing
unfortunately ladies and gentlemen
certainly nothing to laugh about
all of you take a good look at this
that Grill needs to be cleaned because
it's a nasty mess
Jermaine the things that he do around
here and the things that his girlfriend
do around here you're not gonna get
nowhere there's something else I was
supposed to do but I can't remember
man now it's like an all-time low on
bleeding money
he's like a nice dude he's just very
incompetent I'm walking in the door not
having a clue I just opened up the door
I've never seen such an injustice
to a Korean style restaurant what I'd
like to tell you all now is that Miss
Alex is actually from my country team
Alex would you mind coming over please
if you were to sum up the experience
today uh what would you say let me show
you
oh boy oh boy oh boy
salmon
and what's in here
we go
did anyone order asparagus today
really
are you kidding me I just didn't have a
chance to clean out the walk-in the
Chef I got thrown in this position you
you need to be a culinary star to
understand that's [__]
[Music]
smell it
people think this is exaggeration I'm
not [__] around sir would you mind
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen I'd like you all to
stop eating
the kitchen out
foreign
I'm gonna take it from here
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen unfortunately that
was nothing to applaud about we've just
had a dreadful experience the passion's
gone the excitement's gone and it's a
restaurant that's just going through the
motions they have something to show you
you need to see this please take a close
look
[Music]
every other day somebody's complaining
about the quality of the food
one night about six or seven people get
sick from salmonella the word spread
quickly and we've just never recovered
from that
why have we given up I feel like the
owners has given up on us so if they
don't care why should we care you know
you have loyal customers that have been
coming here for decades they have former
loyal customers that do not come here
any longer because of what has happened
based on what you've just seen could you
raise your hands and tell me you're
desperate to rebook and come back for
dinner
for the bottom of my heart I'd like to
apologize for that Dreadful experience
on behalf of the lacklust owners but
what I am going to ask is that you give
me 24 hours and I'd love nothing more
than to see all of you back here
tomorrow and that 24 hours Starts Now
but ladies and gentlemen I got my work
cut out and I hope a big cleaning staff
there'll be a massive cleaning staff
every member of Staff get on your cell
phone and say goodbye to home because
you're in this as much as I am hey
Gordon Ramsay just walked in here and
I'm not gonna be able to come home
there were all these guests like that
came in on a bus I don't know he was
wearing a disguise it was crazy
foreign
answers from the staff so I sent David
and Debbie to clean up the kitchen
what has happened somebody tell me the
leadership man you have no leadership
they need to be present let's talk about
dummy for a man that got his own place
he's never here
wow ready what you see here is what you
got why is he not paying attention his
passion has gone it's it's gone
completely so David goes out and buys
the supplies yes once a week twice a
week every day every day every day yeah
every day we don't have a supplier and
we don't have money why is there no
supplies here because they haven't got
paid these people
couldn't get paid none of us was we
couldn't get paid on time that check is
important that's how we take care of
family you asked a million things of us
to do but you you can't cash our checks